donald trump wants to get back on social
media
the former president was permanently
banned from twitter
facebook is deciding if and when they'll
let him back on
and youtube extended his ban
indefinitely
social media has been one of his biggest
tools arguably perhaps
the biggest rules in his rise to the
politician it seems
increasingly unlikely that he can get
back to social media through
his preferred avenues which would be one
of the mainstream sites is because they
are so
large and every so many people so what
donald trump is doing
now is mulling whether he's going to
start his own social media network and
there are two ways he can do that he can
build his own
or he can buy someone else's and sort of
build on top of it
there are signs pointing to trump's
intention to build his own network
in march jason miller a spokesman for
trump's 2020 presidential campaign
said the former president will return to
social media in quote
about two to three months on his own
platform miller said the new site quote
will be the hottest ticket in social
media
in true trump style he has offered very
few details
if trump is going to build the network
himself
he's going to have to get past apple and
google because they control the app
stores and
it would of course have to be some kind
of mobile app to make this really work
he'd also have to figure out a place for
his service to be hosted
now much of that is usually done through
big companies like microsoft and amazon
those companies have signaled an
increasing reluctance to deal with
conservative social media networks
including a parlor which amazon took off
its cloud service platform
after the january 6 riots the truncated
timeline along with technical barriers
makes it unlikely trump will build his
own platform but there are still ways
for him to get back online
when we talk about whether donald trump
may by
by his way into a social media app we
have to talk about
two existing uh conservative social
media networks
one of them is called gab and one of
them is called parlor in my reporting
i've been told
that donald trump offered to join gab
finally
in exchange for equity in that platform
officially the trump camp denies this
buzzfeed meanwhile says that brad
parscale his former campaign manager
tried something similar tried to get him
an equity stake in parliament exchange
doing that platform
what you see is adding up to a pattern
donald trump
trying to both find a way to get a piece
of
these social media networks to buy his
way into them
and then to build up from there the one
thing that everyone seems very clear
about
is what a donald trump soldier network
would be like in terms of what kind of
content it would be
and it would be the type of toxic
misinformation that he would so want to
distribute
on twitter and facebook in the end it
could set up
another problematic portal of
disinformation misinformation mal
information
that we have to contend with both in the
midterm election
and in the presidential election which
of course he can still run it because
he's only served one term